in the martin scotland there's a 19th
century gothic bridge that crosses a
50-foot ravine
it's officially called overton bridge
but its unofficial name
is the dog suicide bridge oh no
do i even have to ask since the 1950s
hundreds of dogs have mysteriously
jumped off this bridge
and 50 of them died let's find out why
[Music]
built in 1895 the ornate bridge leads up
to overton house
a 19th century manor built by wealthy
industrialist james white
on the outskirts of the village of
milton in the scottish lowlands
it spans overton byrne a deep gorge with
a small river
and hundreds of dogs have attempted to
commit suicide by jumping off this
bridge
and stories about overton bridge are all
over the internet and
have been featured on the tv series the
unexplained files there's even an entire
book
dedicated to this phenomenon but despite
all this attention
the mystery is still unsolved so what's
going on here
there are those who believe that the
suicides are caused by supernatural
forces
they point out that the bridge's
location fits the description of
a thin place which according to celtic
pagan beliefs
is a location where heaven and the earth
meet oh i'd like to see a video on thin
places
that's a good idea another theory blames
the white lady of overton
who haunts the overton house now her
husband john died in 1908
leaving the widow to grieve for over 30
years
and after she died she became the ghost
known as the white lady of overton
according to local legend the white lady
has been seen in the windows of the
house and wandering the grounds
still grieving another even darker story
describes a terrible event that happened
in 1994.
that year a 32 year old father threw his
own baby
into the gorge below because he was
certain that his child was the
antichrist
the baby died the following day and the
father was declared insane
obviously and committed to an
institution locals say that dogs jumped
from the same spot
where the baby was thrown they believe
there's some kind of supernatural
rift that affects dogs behavior now most
animal behaviorists agree that dogs
don't commit suicide
dogs can certainly become depressed
which leads them to waste away and die
slowly
but there's no reason a normal healthy
dog would throw itself
off a bridge so what's going on here
the question is why this bridge why
overton bridge
over all the other bridges that are here
in this country
in 2006 dr david sands a canine
psychologist
investigated the bridge dr sands said
the way that the bridge is constructed
is probably a factor
the walls of the bridge are about waist
high and completely solid
there are also trees and dense greenery
that grow higher than the walls
so there are no visual cues for the dogs
to realize that they're on a bridge
or that there's a drop on the other side
of the wall also the tops of the walls
are tapered
so that if a dog jumps on top of one
it's probably going to fall
even if it realizes it made a mistake so
this explains why a dog would be unaware
that jumping is dangerous
but why would it try to jump in the
first place well dr
sands has a theory for that too he
points out that minks were introduced to
scotland in the 1920s
and began breeding in large numbers in
the 1950s
this is the same time when the suicide
supposedly started
so not only are mink present in the
undergrowth under the bridge
but also squirrels mice all kinds of
forest critters
that dogs enjoy he made me this color
so that i may talk squirrel
my master is good and smart the theory
is the scent of one or more of these
animals grabs a dog's attention
than wanting to chase down the source of
the scent the dog jumps over the wall
without realizing the danger
this theory is supported by the fact
that all of the incidents appear to
happen on dry sunny days when
animal scents carry more clearly and
scotland doesn't get a lot of dry sunny
days so
it kind of stands out dr sands performed
an experiment to see what scents were
most attractive to dogs
he took 10 dogs to a field and they were
the same breeds that jumped off the
bridge
in the field were three containers each
containing an animal scent
seven of the dogs headed straight to the
container containing
the mink scent like right to it minks
emit a strong odor that gets dogs
very excited so the most logical theory
is that on sunny days when scents are
carrying well
long-nosed dogs are catching a whiff of
mink in the undergrowth below the bridge
and in general with dogs the longer the
nose the better their sense of smell
so then driven by their instinct to hunt
and unaware of the dangerous fall
they jump off the bridge in pursuit of
prey
checks out so what we have
seems to be a plausible explanation for
the dog suicide bridge
but locals aren't buying it people who
visit the overton bridge also talk about
experiencing a strange feeling when
they're there
and some have even said they feel an
invisible finger kind of
prodding them to the end of the bridge
and what do you think the jabbing finger
was
the white lady of overton when skeptics
confront locals about the supernatural
theory
many are quick to point out that there
are other bridges just like this
all over the area with the same
characteristics yet dogs are not jumping
so what do you think have we debunked
this story or is there something more
going on here
let us know in the comments i think
what's going on is dogs are dumb
oh and if anyone knows about a fish
suicide bridge i'd be interested in that
not funny
thanks for hanging out with us today my
name is aj that's hecklefish this has
been the y-files
if you had fun or learned anything today
comment like subscribe
share all that stuff really helps out
the channel until next time be safe
be kind and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]
you